nouvelle épreuve aujourd'hui à et
l'épreuve est très simple vous allez
prendre des balles de ping pong
vous allez devoir m regardez vous allez
devoir faire un rebond et m les balles
de ping pong dans les verres à nador
vous allez avoir cinq balles chacun s
vous allez passer 3 par 3 1 kg et celui
qui mettra le plus de balles sera
qualifié pour la finale où il y aura
encore trois personnes puis trois
personnes qui vont s'affronter puis le
gagnant kim affrontera alors alors voyez
qu'il ya un partout entre l'atim baba
était pembe puisqu'on a gagné jamila une
épreuve affirmant je vous rappelle que
j'ai gagné je dirais pas ça qui évite
tout à fait ça bravo parce que
franchement vous auriez pu être mauvaise
puisqu'elle compte vous ne l'êtes pas
mais pas beaucoup
elle devait pas compter celles alors
c'est nous qui comptait pas mâché ses
mots lors du luberon ces jeunes un jules
comité olympique
déjà je voudrais vous dire bravo pour
hier soir ça vous avez été formidables
vous pouvez vous abonner ou plus s'en
passer
c'est
les causes des voix comme ça de londres
à tour de vous êtes magnifique sans
rigoler c'est mon pote s'il faut pas que
vous faites vous de vous et des
chroniques
allez on va démarrer le premier trio qui
va s'affronter à quoi faire ce jeu c'est
vous ça coûte rien ça coûte voilà des
balles de ping-pong saint vert et du
liquide c'est encore moins cher que la
grosse rigolade en syrie trois personnes
ayant un cadeau à gagner bien sûr
puisqu'il ya un magnifique cadeau je
vous le dis est ce qu'on peut me lire
dans l'oreillette
voilà pour savoir le cadeau qui gagne je
crois qu'ils ont encore une console de
jeux une console de jeux un smartphone
voilà à gagner les chéris vous faites
hashtag bien sûr et pmp plus le nom du
chroniqueur sur lequel vous misez ou si
vous misez sur moi vous misez sur baba
ok allez c'est parti
le premier groupe de trois je vais
appeler caroline ithurbide je m'appelle
jean michel maire je vais appeler mon
répond c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
alors si le roi demain
on va démarrer par caron pas dit car
pascal et allez-y vous avez 5 bat celui
qui fait les cinq d'un coup
oui elle après l'autre normal à la
moyenne elle est mal barré non le temps
pour lui d'aller tous merci papa 90 a
fait 5 merci j'ai compté avoue
jean-michel ça va être ça va être de
notre niveau ça te donne envie d'y aller
accor a donc déjà note il te reste plus
que quatre jean pavans et déjà il a
triché
ça compte voilà c est riche aussi quand
même non sinon il en est une qui perçoit
non mais j'avais gagné ça s'est beaucoup
déplacé mon vote aux derniers coups
dernière regard des dernières tenues
mettant au monde étaient les deuxièmes
jude j'avais le ski géraldine mallet et
mon castaldi attention c'est parti on va
laisser ravir sa soeur attention cette
balade là parce qu'on veut après restera
eric naulleau isabelle morini bosc et
valérie bénaïm pour les seniors
la fin de carrière eric ella très très
chaud pour jouer à modérer kaboul
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est lui qui vous a admirablement
représentés hier midi pour me faire
aussi merci battue
[Applaudissements]
oui et bien d'essayer
affronter les braves aurait dit je veux
affronter ce qu'il en a mis deux jeux
j'y crois gilles jahjaga y aller chez
nous ici pas m'excuser mais eric
naulleau elle va à mal et c'est
l'honneur
oui aux dames à isabelle hachey rivasi
met toi bien derrière machine merci tu
la vois aller tu les vois les mères
[Rires]
c'est moi qui ai des jumelles tu vas me
regarder les verts j'ai failli devenir
le retour d'isabelle
m'a déchiré ivan iv qu'on s'inquiète pas
séparables s'amuser
[Applaudissements]
où est la loi avec moi tu t'es mise aux
claquettes et chaussures la soirée celle
d'ariane benoît contrôleur jmicron toit
pour attraper bendit
[Applaudissements]
il ya une pression eric je suis désolé
je le fais puis les eaux dans les
conditions d'équité parfaitement bien
monsieur bien sûr bien sûr
non non non un peu nerfs des questions
sociales on tue les ça rentre ça vous
plaît vous êtes couché votre mère jce
encore la finale
ouais non il ya une finale doit opposer
beijing
alors attention il ya encore un iphone à
gagner vous pouvez vous pouvez parier
sur valérie gastaldy ou moi aller qui va
affronter en finale
là c'est le premier communauté d'accord
au nord voilà six personnes nommées une
au bout de 5 c'est benjamin qui seront
en finale puisque rien n'est mis le tout
bien sûr d'accord je fais des règles
vous voyez
ce n'était pas mis sur wii ou katusha
est actée pmp vous mettez sous le nom du
gagnant de respecter afin satin aller
valérie à l'époque gagné c'était un coup
de chance alors ok fort il faut remonter
au niveau de cette distance ouais ouais
casta toute façon ce qui a été qualifié
voilà puisqu'il fallait que l'on met en
place et on a mis deux journées on m'a
dit on va jouer chacun notre tour avec
cinq balles
comment sais tu perds ton utilisé tant
le supertooth l'attaqué de choix à la
rai a gagné à tranche a tranché groupe à
droite prépare la drôme a dit on pas
costaud ça bosse tous à vos débuts comme
c'est beau chamakh
je le sens sûr de lui les jardins pérou
il est bon s'il vous plaît pas chez moi
ça fait deux jours qui vous fait gagner
parce que si vous gagnez en fin de
semaine vous allez gagner un magnifique
cadeau c'est quand même celui qui vous
représenteront 15 m'a dit j'aimerais que
les gens te respecte la c3 chacun 2.3.2
déjà arrêté de tricher c'est fou ça cm
cic c'est mon problème j'ai des copines
où l'émission est en direct ont peu à
voir l'horaire la soupe et au lieu de me
mettre un truc comme s'ils s'étaient
enregistrés ils souhaitent ils voient
toujours il faut agathois highway to
what en surface
[Applaudissements]
et benji qui vous donne le
il est très beau jeu d'avion
[Applaudissements]
attention il ya donc 2 1 pour votre
équipe chérie s'il vous gagnez en fin de
semaine on verrait vous aurez un
magnifique cadeau le salir est encore
demain et je dis donc je dois gagner les
deux fois voilà lice avec savez vous
dire merci
alors bon benji la question est simple
oui il ya quelqu'un qui a gagné
smartphone sur twitter voilà on va voir
tout de suite le nom de la personne mais
vous la question est simple est-ce que
vous gardez le smartphone ce que vous en
avez gagné 1 également ou est ce que
vous le ferez à quelqu'un du public
pages offre évidemment c'est un truc de
ouf ça fait deux jours que si on est
chez moi parce qu'ils sont capables
tellement des mois la vie
non il sait bien que 30 de rock hard 4
mais attendez je tiens aussi à 64 e
minute
si je tiens 75e minute tout ça parce que
là c'est 52 64 si je tire le 64 cents
piano sera enfin déjà qui le cese donc
on n'évacue ce cette affaire elbaz et
madame vous gagnez smartphones
[Applaudissements]
non c'est le vin le gagnant c'est sale
coup karimama voilà mon karim tu pars
avec un smartphone qui voit là et tu
peux remercier belgique